真根の心ですね 心境の怒り
怒りはたくさんありますけど
真根心として 2つしか書いてないんですね
一つはドームナッササハガタンパティガサンパユッタンアサンカーリカチッタン
テキストにありますから
この文字は全部  2番目は同じ
全部全部同じでササンカーリカチッタン
スートラ編は全部同じ
これは真根心 2つ すごく覚えやすいんです
貪瞋痴のやつも覚えやすい
ドームナッササハガタンパティガサンパユッタンアサンカーリカチッタン
ドームナッササハガタンパティガサンパユッタンササンカーリカチッタン
日本語になると 有愚瞋恚相
書きましょうか で パーリもドームナッササハガタンっていうのは有愚
サハガタンまで 有愚ってこれはドームナッササハガタン
日本語の方が短いんですけどね
サハガタン パティガっていうのは瞋恚ですね
サンパユッタンというのは相という風に訳しているんです
アサンカーリカっていうのは無行でササンカーリカっていうのは有行で漢字に入れ替えるとすごい短いんです
で 説明もまたすごくそんなに難しくはない
で 私たちはこの物事をいろんなものを認識している過程において
認識するから見る 聞く
嗅ぐ 味わう 体で触れる
頭で考えるという 4種類なんですね
眼耳鼻舌身意という 6つの働きが認識というんですね
その時はまあ楽しくなっちゃうと
それはもう貪瞋痴なんですね
ドームナッササハガタンと出てきましたから
それほど楽しくないんだけど
嫌じゃない場合も貪瞋痴なんですね
で この場合は違う 有愚と書いているんですね
この見て楽しくはないんです
暗いんです 嫌なんです
見たものは本当は自分の立場から見れば見たくないもの
聞いたものは自分から見れば聞きたくないもの
食べたものは自分から見れば食べたくないもの
そういう風に自分がした
認識したくないものを対象を認識すると
その対象について 何て言いますか
対立というか もうぶつかっちゃうんですね
拒否 拒否するんですね
拒否するためにその対象を認識しなくちゃいけないんだから
だから認識した対象を心から心の状態から拒否したがる対象について怒りが生まれちゃうんですね
ですから 見たくないものを見ていると気持ち悪いでしょうに
聞きたくないものを聞いていると気持ち悪いでしょうに
味わいたくないものを味わうと気持ち悪くなっちゃうし
触れてほしくないものに体が触れちゃうと気持ち悪くなっちゃうし
明るくはならない 暗い
ですから怒りの心っていうのは暗い心
そこで簡単に考えてみてください
この性格的に暗い人々を言うんですね
強烈に怒りを持ってるんですね
みんな理解しないんです
いいよ 私は全然怒りませんよと平気で言うんです
怒らないかもしれませんだけど
怒りの心なんですね ずっと育てているのはこの暗い人々は
だからなかなか普通の心理学ではもう治るのは難しいんです
それは怒りだとわかってないんだから
え？ここのこの体の問題
あっち悪いこっち悪いと文句ばっかり言ってる人やら
いろんなことでまあああだこうだとか文句言ったりする人々やら
とにかく明るくない場合はもう性格的に暗いんだったら
それはもう怒りの心なんです
そこで簡単に捕まってみれば
自分を直すことも簡単にできるんです
ですから 怒りの心の場合は
感覚としてはドマナッサということになっちゃうんです
そっちが上という感じが書いてますけど
その感じによって何を感じるか
私はあまり感じませんだけど
ソマナッサではハッピーという楽しいということで
ですからそちらの反対なんですね
ソマナッサの反対の言葉はドマナッサ
で これはどういう まあちょっと文法的に分析しますけど
で ソマナッサっていうことはこういう風に作ることなんですね
これはスということと
マナということと これが格変化で入っちゃうんですね
SSA は で パーリ語だったら SSA が書かないでサーだけ書くんです
だからスというのは良い
いいという意味で マナというのは心で
ッサっていうのは就いてるという格変化で
そこでス・マナあるということで
ソマナッサになっちゃうんですね
それは発音的に変化するんですね
心は良いと明るいといいということで
スというこの言葉の反対のことはドゥなんです
DU のドゥ それに全部つければ
ドゥとマナとサーつければドマナッサということが出てきちゃうんですね
まあそれはまあ文法的に分解するとそうなっちゃうんです
で パーリ語サンスクリット語は全部この動詞だから
マナっていうのは名詞なんですけど
それはマンという動詞から出てくるんですね
マンというのは To think考えるということで知るということで
ですから知るという動詞からいろいろ工夫して
こういう形容詞やら名詞やら全部作ってるんです
サンスクリット語文化は全部動詞の文化なんです
とにかく ドゥというのはよくない Bad
という これは Good
それは Bad 接尾語はだいたい Good と Bad という意味ぐらいのもう prefix なんですね
これは英語で prefix と言うんです
こちらの入れる語尾に入れるものは suffix と言うんです
こちらは格変化で こちらは変化しません
頭につける言葉は変化しない
最後につける言葉は変化する
ですからこの そんなにこの言語学は要りませんだけど
ドゥーマナッサンティの心はあまり良くないと
暗いと 明るくない 楽しくない
それはわかるわけよ 皆さんに言えば
皆様方は例えば随分ものすごく自分の好物の食べ物があって
それを食べると気持ち悪いわけないでしょ
その時は楽しいんです
全然食べたくないものは
何か病気になったわけか
あるいはお医者さんに言われたわけか
もう他の食べ物は全然作ってくれなかったわけか
なんとかもう否応なしに食べると
もうもうしょうがなく食べると
その時は気持ちはあまり良くないんですね
だからそんな差なんです
感覚ですか ですから それに融合というか
他にどんな言葉使うかわかって
それは私は知りませんだけど
こちら融合の意味はそういう意味なんです
心は暗いと で そこその説明はそれだけで十分だと思います
ですから 我々は怒りの心は瞑想で認識する場合は
自分が明るいか暗いかということで認識すればいいんです
瞑想途中でも自分が気持ちいいか
あるいは暗いか 楽しく
楽しいというのはもうわいわいと楽しさに出なくてもいいんです
もういわゆるやりたくてやってるんですかと
なんかやらなくちゃいけないんだからやってるんですかとか
その場合は暗いんですね
ですから その僅かな差で怒りの心か欲の心かとわかるんです
それだけで 次にパティガサンパユッタム
心のサッというのは水に何が溶けているかという問題と同じですから
井戸水か水道の水かと言えるのは
その何 全く平等な水の中に何が溶けているんですかということである
そこで心も同じく一つしかない
そこでこの心にパティガというものが溶けているんです
パティガっていうのはこちらで心気と日本語で書いてますけど
言葉の意味はコンフランテーション
ぶつかるという意味なんですね
反対する 否定する 拒否するっていう意味なんですね
パティガっていうのは
拒否すること 働きが溶けている
拒否する気持ち 反対する気持ち
溶けている だからこちらでは相応という風に入ってるんだ
だから心の中に心というのを認識することと
認識すると同時に その認識する自体を拒否したくなるならば
それを否定したくなるならば
それを怒りなんですね
パティガはどういう風な文法的にどういう風に出ますかというと
パティ それと サンスクリット
ハンという動詞から過去過去形の分詞作っちゃうんですね
このサンスクリットで
まあ最後につけるのはタなんですけど
そこは皆様わからないかもしれません
わからない方がいい 簡単です
わかったら私は大変困りますから
これ難しいんです いっぱいものを覚えておかないと
この文法の分析ができないんです
パティっていうのは against
何々に対する against
も反対というものでもないんです
大体 例えば自分 英語で言えば
私は壁に背を持たれますよと I
lie against the wall. 壁に反対して壁ぶつかってという風な意味じゃないんです
そういうパティっていうのはとにかく反対にという意味で
ハンというのはもう殺すとか切るカッという殺すというような意味なんです
壊す ハンの元々は殺すということなんですね
それで過去形の過去分詞形です
タは それで この円のンとターとくっついちゃって
また変化して ある法則によってガになるんです
それはハンノウ動詞のカテゴリーによるものであって
それはもうすごいもう違う世界に文法の世界はかなりややこしいんです
サンスクリット語 パーリ語の
動詞は 10種類のカテゴリに入れてるんで
このそのその 10種類によって変化は違うんです
たまにただそのまま正直に付ける場合もあります
ここで正直に付けないで版とこれと一緒になって GH のガになっちゃうんです
ですからパティガになっちゃうんです
ですからパティガには何々に反対してそれを壊すという
で 言葉から見ればそんなにも恐ろしい言葉ではないんです
何かまあなくす 日本語で言えばなくすというぐらいの意味なんです
ですから いい意味でも仏教で使っています
例えばラーガーナンパティガッターヤ
ラーガっていうのは欲
欲をパティガッターヤなくすために
その時は怒りという意味ではないんです
ドーサーナンパティガッターヤ
モーハーナンパティガッターヤとか
そういう普通の言葉で出てくる言葉なんです
こっちでは専門用語で使ってるんです
ですから たとえパーリ語
サンスクリット語を知っていたっても
これ専門用語で使っているか
普通の言葉で使っているかという区別もしなきゃ
もう理解しないところもあります
いや それパティガの説明で
あまり説明しちゃうと分からなくなりますから
どこを見ても動詞だけ見つかる
動詞しかない で パティガっていうのはそういうことで
怒りという風にも訳できるし
でも厳密に言えば認識した対象を拒否する
否定する なくしたくなる
例えば人が私たちにものすごく叱ってるんだと
こちら怒っちゃうでしょ
怒りが生まれる その時はその耳に入る音はもうなくしたいんです
やめなさいということで聞きたくないんだと
聞きたくないと思っちゃったら
そこに出てくるのは怒りなんです
で 我々常識で怒りというのはそこで怒ってから
あんた何そんなことを言ってるんですかとか
それは後の話なんです
怒りが生まれて時間経ったところでやってる行動から怒ってるんだと
そうじゃなくて 聞く瞬間でもう心は暗くなってるんです
暗くなった瞬間から 仏教アビダンマからもう怒りの心
それはどんどん強烈になってくると
言葉で表したり 体で表したりする
さらにそれは反芻すると
いろんなコンプレックスになったりはする
自信が失ったりとか 自信がないとか
行動はあまりできないとかね
いう人々はもうかなり長い間怒りを反芻して反芻して
それで自信がなくなってるだけです
もともとは怒りなんです
それでカウンセラーのところに行ったら
あんたすごい怒りですよと言ってくれないんです
いろんなことを分析したり
精神分析やらもう対抗させたり
いろんなことをしたりして
まぁ時間の無駄使い それでも治らないんです
自信はつけてくれません
人は簡単に何のことなく行動すればいいんです
そこで自分をコントロールするためには
自分の良心に従って行動すればいいんです
そこで何かしたところで失敗しましたと
みんなに認めてくれなかったと
みんなに批判されたと
そういうことを頭に入れちゃって
その怒りなんですね あ
認めてくれなかった 分かってくれなかった
理解してくれなかったとか
うまくいかなかったとか
反応が少なかったとか
そこで気持ち悪くなるでしょ
それは怒りなんです それから
その同じ怒りの心をもうできるだけもうまたまた妄想して
頭の中で回転させて繁殖する
だから妄想は危ないのはこの回転するたびにエネルギーが増えるんです
だから考えるとか何とか平気で
人間っていうのはすごくよく考えなくちゃいけないと偉そうなこと言ってますけど
僕は堂々と言うでしょ
考えるなと 考えると人間何やってますか？と
何か概念をどんどん頭の中で回転させる
だからどんな方向へ回転するかということは
本人にはコントロールできない
怒りだったら怒りの方向へ回転してしまった
欲だったら欲の方向へ回転してしまった
そういうものに考えてると言えないんです
仏教で考えてるところはしっかりと因果法則によって
これだからこうなって
こうだからこうなったよっていうことで
それには考える必要ないんです
もう原因見たら結果が見えますから
ガラスが割れたならば
そこに野球の球があったならば
この球がぶつかってガラスが割れましたと
割れましたと それで一生懸命苦労して考える必要はないでしょうに
ですから 智慧には考えることは要りませんし
考えるというのは我々考えると言ってるのはもう妄想概念のこの回転なんですね
意識の回転というのはものすごく自動的回転だから
いくらでも回転する だからいろんな精神的な問題が出てくる
ちょっと何かやったところで自分が怒り作っちゃう
作った怒りをずっと繁殖する
繁殖したら自信がなくなったとか
体が病気になったとか
もう胃が悪くなったとか
ああだこうだとか ストレスが溜まったとか
そういう人々はみんな暗いことだけは確かなんです
ですから 今の世の中の精神的な病気な人々のもう九十パーセント以上怒りで病気になってるんです
少ないなんですけど 欲で病気になってるんです
まあ怒りの心これぐらいなんですね
そこで怒り いろいろあります
嫉妬することを怒り なぜか嫉妬すると気持ちいいんですか？って気持ち悪いんですね
暗いんですね 嫉妬っていうのは
他人のいいことを自分が認めたくないということを嫉妬なんですね
けちつけたくなるんですね
それは嫉妬です そこでもう一つあります
物惜しみですか マッチャリアというものがあります
自分持っているものは他人は共有するのは
使うのは嫌なんです それは私のものだと
ケチをする ケチをする時も欲じゃなくて
それは怒りなんです ケチをする場合はいろいろある
物惜しみ そういう人も暗いんですね
それも同じく人 例えば自分がいろいろ能力から財産からいろんなものを持っている
それは人にも分かって分けてあげて
その人々もその喜びが違うのは嫌ということですね
大体みんな自分のものを持ちたくなるんですね
自分の家 自分の持ち物
これは私のものです それは私のもの
私のもの 個人的にすごく自分のものだと執着しているものを
他の人もちょっと貸してくれと言っちゃったら
もうすごく気持ち悪くなっちゃうんです
あげたくなっちゃうし
あげたくなくなっちゃうし
その場合は物惜しみという心性が働いてるんです
それも仏教から見れば怒りなんですね
なぜかって心は暗いんだから
それからクックッて後悔する
後悔する時でも心は暗いでしょ
何かやらなかった方が良かったのにとかね
やった方が良かったのにとか
その二種類の後悔があるんですね
何かをして あ やらなかった方が良かったんではないかと後で考えちゃう
そうすると暗くなっちゃうんですね
それを後悔と言うんですね
何かやらなかった そうすると
あ やった方が やっておいた方が良かったんではないかと後悔する
悔しくなる それも怒りです
そういう風にいろんな種類の怒りがある
だからだからといって怒りに怒りの行動から心を作ろうと思っちゃったら
心のかすばがものすごくたくさん
たくさんになっちゃうんです
人は怒るだけで何も一言葉も言わない場合もありますね
怒って黙ってるとか 怒って言葉を喋る人もいて
怒って行動する人もいるんですね
ただ怒ったところで物を壊したりとか
立ってとか出て行っちゃうとか
それも行動ですから 怒っても何のことなくニコニコしながらそのままいる人もいるし
本当は心の中で怒っている
ですから 怒りいろいろなんですね
怒ったところで もう誰でもいいんだから
誰かに当たるって人もいるし
あるいは人に害悪をする人もいるし
喧嘩する人もいるし 人を殺す人もいるし
戦争まで行く人もいるし
戦争もするのは怒りなんですね
決して楽しく喜んで戦争するという歴史はないんです
すごい怒りを持つと 相手を倒さなくちゃ
殺さなくちゃ けさなくちゃという気持ちで戦争しているんです
世の中の国のスケールで考えちゃう
っていうのも よく戦争に話しかけてくれる
戦いかけてくれる国々がいっぱいあるんですね
脅したりとかね こうしたら経済制裁だよとか
ああだこうだ それ全部怒りなんですね
まあこんな方かどうかはわかりませんだけど
このアメリカのこの偉い人々なんか
テレビ出てるそうな 中国はああだこうだとか
韓国はああだこうだとかって
もうものすごい恐ろしい怒りの塊で
僕は感じちゃうんですね
この人々に国の責任任せましたと
世界の責任任せました
ヤクザの方もよっぽどいいんじゃないか
ヤクザっていうのは一応合理的な怒りを持ってるだけのことだからね
あれ合理的でもないんです
怒り煽る もうあおいでくれるんですね
あの あの韓国のなんかの北朝鮮の潜水艦がいたところで
まあ落ち着けばいいのに
落ち着いてそれなりに何かやればいいのに
国際的にやっぱりもう韓国はそれにももうしかるべき態度を取る権利がありますよ
ああだこうだと で 怒りを応援してくれる
怒らせてあげる そういうのは国際的政治だとかああだこうだ言ったりする
もう正しい頭のいい人が政治やってるんだったら
韓国にすぐ言うのは まあそれはけしからぬことかもしれませんだけど
落ち着いてちゃんと調べなさいと
調べてからそれなりに行動しなさいと言った方が正しいのに
そうじゃないんです だから一人が怒ったら向こう側も怒ったりしてね
大変な状態なんですね
世の中って それでイスラエルに例えてイスラエルとパレスチナでもですかね
すごいもう信じられないほど互いに怒りを持ってるんだから
ですから そういう怒りは
例えば国と国の怒りはどんな心ですか？と
それから親が子供に怒ることはどんな怒りですか？それ怒りあるたびに心一つ一つ決めちゃうと
どれぐらい怒りの心が出てくる
それは数がないんですね
その場合は 両親がいつでも子供に対して怒るでしょうに
その度にその怒りが違うし
両親が他の人とも怒っちゃうし
買い物に行ったら店の人とも怒る可能性あるし
それと子供と怒る怒りがまた違うし
いろんな怒りがありますよ
ですから そこではもう考えないんです
それはヨーロッパ的な知識です
そういうつかみにくい
まあそこで 海の水を測ってみ
一つ一つ測ってみるというようなやり方で
そうじゃなくて まあ 1滴の水を海の水に入れたら
これは真水で こういうものは全部そんなもんだよと決めた方が理解しやすいんです
ですから アビダンマではそういう方向で心は暗くなっちゃったら
そこは対象は嫌ですよと
心が暗くなったということは
認識した対象が本人が拒否しているんです
そこで怒りの心と決めましょう
そうすると一つしかない
怒りの心 対象を拒否する
人しかないんだけど 性格的に無行と有行の 2つがあるんですね
すぐもう何の準備もなくもうパッと怒る人は無行でゆっくり怒る人は有行で
それだけの差 だから性格的にひらめきの
まあひらめきってのはいいことだから
すぐサッとひらめく人も性格だから怒るとこもサッと怒っちゃうんです
理解鈍くてすごい時間かかるんだと
そういう人々は怒る時も同じく
まあすぐその場で気づかないんです
あれあれ 私はけなされたんではないかと
後で分かって怒るんです
で 消える時も同じ法則で
すぐひらめく人はすぐ忘れちゃうんです
ゆっくり時間かけてゆっくりひらめいたものはもうずっと残っちゃうし
怒りの場合もサッと怒る人はサッと冷めちゃうんです
滅多に怒らない人を怒っちゃったら
これ何年でも怒りが続いてしまいます
同じことを同じ人に 例えばある一人の人が何かについてすぐ怒ってしまったと
すぐカッとなったと そういう怒りはすぐ消えちゃう
その同じ人があることについて徐々にもう嫌になってきて
怒りが生まれたならば
それはそんな簡単には消えません
ですから この同じ人にも有行無行
もうバラバラ無茶苦茶で生まれるんです
だから無行の人は一生徹底的に決まっちゃって無行っていうわけでもないんです
あるものはサッとひらめくし
あるものはそんな簡単にひらめかないっていうことはいろんないろんなことあります
その差はもう前も言ったようにそれほど気にする必要ないんです
それは性格の差で それはまあ修行に役に立つから
仏教で使っているだけのこと
我々は経験でよく知ってますからね
まあいきなりパッとカッとなった人は
まあその怒った早く怒った人は早く冷めると
ということはよく知っているんだな
それは怒りの心 2つ では次に行きます
サティガとドーサ ドーサとサティガって同じ意味なんですか？同じと考えていいですか？ まあ意味として同じなんですけどね
ドゥッシャというのはドーサという言葉はこの言葉から出てくるんです
パーリ語でドゥッシャと言うんです
ドゥッシャというのはコーラプション
コラプト 汚れると ドゥッシャからドーサという言葉が出てくるんです
汚れたと 汚くなったと
それは怒りに使うんですね
ですからドーサという言葉使うと
一般の言葉としては汚れたという意味でも使うんです
それで体の病気の場合も
同じくドーサという言葉も使ってるんです
ですから 例えばラーガ
貪瞋痴ありますね 貪瞋痴にラーガという場合があります
それでラーガドーサと言えるんです
その場合はラーガに汚れてラーガと怒り
欲と怒りではないんです
それが次の言葉でドーサからドーセーナ
ドーセテーと言うんです
怒りで汚れて欲で汚れて無知で汚れて
だから汚れたという意味もあるんです
専門用語としては怒り
ドーサ その場合 汚れっていうのは暗くなったっていうこと
まあ誰でもやっぱり明るく元気で楽しく生きたいという基本的なものはありますが
その立場から見て 明るくないんだったら汚れてるんだ
明るくないんだったら暗いんだから
意味は同じ とにかく専門用語として
仏教ではこの煩悩という言葉がありますね
煩悩に仏教のパーリ語ではキレーサと言うんですね
キレーサ キレーサっていうのは汚れさっていう意味なんです
それは動詞そのままサンスクリット語でクリシュナという字ですから
このクリシュナという言葉はパーリ語に変化してキレーサになっているんです
で この場合は動詞はクリシュで
タは kiitaはつける言葉で
そのまま掃除機に繋げられるんです
変化してないんです クリシュナはパーリ語になっちゃうとキリッタになるんです
こちらで使われるのはタなんですけど
タは変化するんですね TTHA
に だからパーリ語になっちゃうとちょっとまあ変わってしまっちゃうんです
キレーサという変化はサンスクリット語でないんです
サンスクリット語でキレーサはクレーシャと言わなくちゃいけないんです
このキレーサはサンスクリット語になるとクレーシャ
で ありますけど まあほとんど仏教用語なんですね
ですから あまりたくさんクレーシャ
クレーシャという言葉を使うと
この純粋サンスクリット語じゃなくて
仏教サンスクリット語と言うんです
サンスクリット語も種類があります
仏教で使っているサンスクリット語と
もう大乗経典やら南伝教
北伝経典というのはサンスクリット語だからね
汚れているサンスクリット語と言うんですね
いわゆるこの純粋なサンスクリット語文化から見れば
もう変な言葉がいっぱいあるんだと
そういうことでハイブリッドサンスクリットと言うんです
ハイブリッドというのは何ですかね
違う種類と一緒に使って新しい新しく作ったりしますね
そういうのをハイブリッドと言うんです
だからブディストサンスクリットかブディストハイブリッドサンスクリットか
どっちかっていう言葉を使っているんですね
仏教で使っている言葉を区別するために
そういう話は置きましょう
次にあるのは貪瞋痴の痴
痴の心 それまた二つ それはちょっと難しいです
で ですから  [背景の雑音]心が 2つありまして
ウペッカーサハガタン
ヴィチキッチャーサンパユッタンチッタン
このウペッカーサハガタンというのはもう勉強しているんです
2番目はウペッカーサハガタン
ウッダッチャサンパユッタンチッタン
この文字はローマ字はテキストにもありますから
この 24 ページに 24 ページの 6番目の項目ですね
黒板に書いたのはこの覚えやすい方法で書いたんです
こちらではもう全部一つの行にセンテンスでまとめているんだから
そこはまあちょっと理解しにくいかも
でも言葉はそのまま出ていますから
別々にしてウペッカーサハガタン
ヴィチキッチャーサンパユッタンチッタン
ウペッカーサハガタン
ウッダッチャサンパユッタンチッタン
僕ら覚える場合は 2つ
ヴィチキッチャーサンパユッタンチッタン
ウッダッチャサンパユッタンチッタン
他のは全部同じですから
それで理解すればいいです
そこで説明に入ります
ウペッカーサハガタンというのは
このわかりやすい感覚から言っちゃうんです
それは瞑想する人々のことを考えているんです
自分の心をどう理解するかと
この感覚で理解しやすいんです
気持ちいいか 気持ち悪いかとかね
その方が理解しやすいと思いますよ
楽しいか楽しくないか
だから怒りはわかりやすいんですね
欲もわかりやすい 欲っていうのは結構楽しいというか
気持ちいいんですね で
中立に気持ち 例えばもうまあ普通に音楽が流れてるんだったら
BGM として聞いて別に気持ち悪くはないんだけど
そんなに気持ちいいわけでもないし
だから気持ち悪くならないんだから
その場合 ウペッカーと言うんです
シャーと 怒りの場合は確実に気持ち悪いんですね
暗いんですね その区別は簡単にできる
そこで無知の場合もウペッカーサハガタン
感じは気持ちいいか悪いかと言えないんですね
ですから 無知の人は暗いとは言いにくいんです
怒りの人は暗いんです
それはもう正真正銘暗い
で 欲中心の人は結構明るいんです
だから世の中で成功する場合は
欲ある人は結構成功しちゃうんですね
楽しいし もう金儲かりたくて
もういろんな大胆なことをやりたくて
もう楽しく このスポーツにしてもね
すごいキツいことをやって
もうメダルなんかあんなちっちゃな何も意味のないあれもらってものすごく楽しがっちゃうんですね
それを家で飾っておくとかね
でもそういうことで楽しがっちゃいますから
その性格なんです だからいろいろな世界でそういう人々は成功しちゃうんですね
暗い人はなかなか成功しないんですね
逆らうんだから 暗い人の場合は成功するのはまあ戦争とか革命とか
そんなもんなんですね
成功っていうのは何かやるのは
でも後で結果は良くなくなっちゃって
もうダメになってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 例えばソ連でアメリカと比べると
アメリカの方が欲中心にですから力強くなって成功します
成功と僕は言いませんだけど
まあ生き続けているし
怒りに乗ってそれで革命できてたソ連がもう崩壊して終わってしまったし
そこで理解はしていないんだけど
中国なんかはもう革命は怒り中心だから
そこで行けばもうもう壊れるぞと分かったんですね
経験が見て そこでじゃあ欲に行こうと
言って あの亡くなった小何でしたっけ
鄧小平 鄧小平さんとかね
そういう人々はまあ一応もう欲に行こうと
欲に行くと自分の社会システムは守られるとと言っているんですね
ですから ああいう方向でいけば
中国はもう崩壊はしないんですね
それはまあよく事実として見える
見えるもので そういう人々はわかっているわけじゃないんです
気がついてもないし ですからこの怒りは